how about the lady that was [ __ ]
talking about on Twitter about the
[ __ ] comedy club oh this [ __ ] was so
funny god this [ __ ] was so funny
I waited it let me [ __ ] do it here
it's right here
god this made me laugh dude Courtney
pong her name is tonight I shut down a
string of misogynistic stand-up comics
as in I've walked on stage in the middle
of one of them talking addressed the
audience offered a full refund told them
it would not be tolerated here and
pulled the show and then a follow-up
tweet and it's comics from our theater
and oh and it pulled the show and it's
comics from our theater immediately
lights on go home I haven't this was the
best part I have never felt more alive
than right now
hey good okay this is the best because
obviously she can do what she wants if
it's her comedy club great you can put
whoever whatever comics you want on
there but dude if you want to control
what people are saying and what jokes
they're making don't have a comedy club
how bad is it gonna be holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
the people the people that were
responding we're killing dude the fact
that that makes her feel alive is so
funny
you ever been wrong in front of a bunch
of people you know how alive you feel
when that happens or just when you're
bombing on stage you know how live you
feel that's what she was doing
feeling alive because she was being
wrong dude don't have a comedy show if
you're gonna say you know it's like the
best thing about the comedy story is you
go up there you you you know you work
your [ __ ] out you fail if you fail and
you succeed if you succeed but nobody's
saying don't say this don't say that
Mitzi shore rolling over in a [ __ ]
grave so funny safe comedy as an unfunny
comedy
so I wrote this I wrote just crying
emoji crying laughing emoji and somebody
somebody wrote somebody wrote something
like I don't get why are you laughing
this is a good thing somebody wrote and
I immediately made this all about myself
wondering how on earth also there were
17 people in the audience dude this was
the article about it there was an
article written terribly in some [ __ ]
stupid thing here it is it was called
the universal hub calm okay
misogynist comedians stay out of
Rosalynn dale made-up town that [ __ ]
it's you know would be in a [ __ ] WB
show Roslindale tonight on Roslindale a
girl with red hair gets upset the owner
of a comedy spot in Roslindale shutdown
issues of stand-up sets last night after
she says she'd had enough of a string of
racist sexist jokes I love that the word
jokes is in there like okay once that
happens everything's moot Kourtney pong
who owns the Razi Square Theatre
shortened it's a [ __ ] to say it's the
Rajee square oh wait I want to write
this down dad with over the next 40
minutes or so she runs improvident let's
other group put on stand-up shows over
the next 40 minutes or she cringe listen
at a number of this [ __ ] jokes and
finally had enough when one guy told a
joke about how you couldn't understand
why you were fired him for making women
customers ride in the trunk like okay
fine I'm sure that's a bad joke I wasn't
there it was probably stupid
but like so funny to see it in writing
like that was way that she said is when
she realized wait a minute I own this
place
should have realized it sooner it's your
don't ever forget that sitting at the
sound table in the back of the theater
she hit a button that rang a loud Bell
Wow dude you know big brother walked
into the front and announced the night
was over and that she would give refunds
to the for paying customers and the
other 13 people in the room were friends
of the performers yeah no [ __ ] she wrote
it's not okay she says it's not okay
it's not who we are she told the
audience is and somebody from the
audience said is this a joke or is this
part of the act
punk said she chose Rosendale very
deliberately as a site for her 49 seat
theater to get away from stuff like this
then thought even though she knew she
could have made a lot more money
someplace like downtown oh man then she
wrote no woman in the world would have
wanted to stand in that room laughs last
night I mean that's not true
it's so [ __ ] egotistical to think
that everybody just wants to feel what
you feel and hear what you hear and
think what you think it's like how could
you [ __ ] have that in your head just
if you don't want to run your business
the way that's fine but you're not gonna
get good comedians to do it that's it
anyway that's all I want to say about
that but it was so [ __ ] funny and my
buddy Earl Skakel wrote under it he
wrote where is the in quotes where is
this gig and can I have an incredible
set there he put a picture of Jeremy
Piven under it could I have an
incredible set there that's so funny
Jeremy Piven does stand-up